all right guys so as you asked for it
i'm gonna here make a small video where
i do some technical analysis on the spy
which is the etf track of the s p 500
i'm gonna analyze the whole move
starting in
after the 208 crisis in march 2009
going until let's see for how long but
definitely we are not done here for the
smoother so i'm gonna
use mostly elliot way theory but i'm
also gonna use
some fibs to find my targets and i'm
also gonna use of course
trend lines so let's get into it
[Music]
so the first wave so i'm doing it with
you guys i've done that before of course
so a bit i know a bit what i'm doing but
i forgot exactly what i did so let's see
if i find something similar
or not this is for me pretty clear so
each time you do
this kind of analysis let's start on the
weak thing guys so we go
more we see more clearly what is
happening here my internet is a bit slow
in the hotel so i'm sorry for the
lagging so here we go we have it
so one two three four five so i know
this is a four because i have already
analyzed
this move before guys but here of course
there was a question
a lot of people thought the fifth wave
was actually going
here that we get something like this you
know and that
and that the covet crisis was the
beginning of a new move down
i was thinking like this as well at this
time but here i knew
quite early that this scenario was not
the
correct one so now my analysis is like
this
uh i'm very convinced that this is what
we are having to know that you're
counting is correct guys you need to
find always five waves
in each motif wave all right so we're
doing it
one two is even here to know where the
first is going one two three four five
so first is going here
one two three four five okay second
three four five and even in this one
okay here it doesn't really matter we
could have something like this
i'm not gonna go to this level of detail
i'm gonna keep it like this
then we're having our small abc's as
usual guys
so here we had a zigzag so we expect a
flat
here it's not a flat it's uh
it's definitely not a flat another three
goes
here actually again
okay it's more something like this all
right
and here we had this megaphone pattern
that i was analyzing with you guys very
nice let's put it in pink
okay so this is a triangle guys nothing
more than a triangle all right you can
see
a b c d ish all right
so this is a beautiful triangle that
occurred in the force wave so you know
triangles very often occurs in in occur
in force waves so sometimes you're going
to have
um zigzag and flat sometimes flat and
zigzag
and sometimes zigzag and triangle or
flatten triangles basically you often
have triangles in the phosphate so this
is a very interesting situation
because i don't see often those
expanding triangles
but here i was very sure that this was
actually bullish when we had so let me
go back on the daily
now i'm gonna analyze the fifth wave
right because we are in the fifth wave
and then i'm going to give you targets
so i've done already this in the video i
sent you before so this is still holding
and but then i
i guess you guys are interested to get
maybe some information
about what is happening in this move so
i'm gonna come to this
as well so now let's analyze this whole
move up
so here same thing guys
we are going to use elliot to find what
is happening
so this is the one
okay we're having something like this so
there is a fourth wave that is going to
come guys
i don't know when but it's coming it
will come this would be a very nice
buying opportunity i think probably it's
going to rebound
on this trend line again okay you see
here
so i'm connecting this high with this
high and you can see here rejected
rejected rejected we break it it was a
bit messy but then we had one two three
four reactions and i remember guys the
whole way up i was saying that here it's
a very nice levels to
buy because i know we are in this third
wave so now let's analyze this
third wave so we're gonna get more
information definitely it's gonna be
longer
i mean not definitely we don't know yet
okay so
one we start with a flat you can see
this time okay
so we haven't finished okay so we have
time guys we have time
for me we have time so here we have a
flat so we expect a zigzag
or a triangle in the false wave
of this third so first let's see this
one
this one is not obvious guys
okay i'm not so sure about this counting
so i'm not i don't really know where the
third wave is gonna go but let's try to
find some targets and then we're gonna
try to find some levels below which
that are telling us that the third is
done we're gonna use uh fibs we're going
to use
divergences guys i'm coming to it very
soon so for now
let's try maybe to find some targets so
let's use fibs right away
up so you see first wave is here so
typical third wave would go to the 470
area so exactly where i put it you see
so i start to be used to that guys so
yeah the typical third wave would go to
the 470 area so here we're gonna
probably have some selling pressure
i would say okay so let me put this like
this
all right let me get rid of that here
we're probably gonna find some selling
pressure at 470 guys
and then correction so then the
correction would go as usual to the
top of the third or bottom of the force
so it would go guys to
this kind of levels all right so the 400
level would be a nice level to buy to
play the fifth of the third
here and then this force wave would
probably not go much lower
so i would say if you guys want to enter
the
s p 500 trade with the spy that i'm
having here that is just
10 times less i can see that force waves
most likely they would come
to the 400 level even maybe less here
maybe you would only go here
so i would say right now that the 400
level is an amazing level to buy yes
okay so five six
percent seven percent lower is a very
nice level to buy
of course you can use a stop loss around
this area guys just below the
purple trend line here that is upward
sloping trend line
that is actually making a very nice stop
loss so maybe by 400 stop loss to
390 you know because you never know this
is the crisis that it's still going on
you never know when they're gonna you
know stop injecting liquidity in this
market because this is the main reason
guys the market is going higher of
course the economy is doing better
because we have this massive liquidity
injections and the inflation is gonna be
most likely handled even if we go
slightly above two you know to three
percent
uh they're not gonna start increase
rates that's what paul said
i think one month ago i'm not following
very closely what is the policy of the
fed right now but i'm pretty sure it has
not changed it will not
change guys so as long as we have some
kind of problems
the money injection would keep uh
happening and the market would keep
going
higher so for me we need to have new
information for this market to revert
for now the covet crisis will not make
it revert i don't believe it once again
the issues could come from
too high inflation something like this
you know but to me we are far from it
for now i'm very bullish on this market
let's see for example here what are the
divergences telling us
so let's zoom in a little bit okay so we
completed this false wave
so here what is the macd doing
only going higher i'm looking for
bullish hidden divergences
you see for example here we're having
some market going higher
maxi going lower so you can see the snp
is very strong here it was giving us
some hints about
its bullish development the market
making new highs when the macd is making
lower lows new lows sorry when the macd
is making
lower lows let me go to the four hours i
want to see if
this third wave is done soon i have the
470 target for this
third wave here the macd is same going
higher so
i'm not having those divergences on the
four hours i'm looking for bearish
regular divergences as well you know
market making new high
with the macd going lower but it's not
the case here you can see the macd is
going higher so we are good
here for example we had some you can see
up
between here and here the market making
new highs and no the magazine was making
me high so it was not
a divergence okay guys so i don't want
to make it too long
let me just give you my target for the
fifth wave for the very long term
so i'm gonna do the usual stuff guys i'm
gonna measure
the three first waves okay from here
to here and i'm gonna apply to the
bottom of the force guys
all right and this is giving me
different scenarios
so i just do it with the third wave i
can do it with the third wave like i did
in my video i can do it from here
actually
i prefer to do it from here and it's
going to give me slightly different
ratios but i prefer those
so this is giving me for an extended
fifth a target of
5900 so this is a different method from
the one i used in my previous video i
just measured here the whole
move up which is actually another
technique that i like to use or i can
measure just this one
and then in my first video i give you
the 1.618 or the 2.618
which was the 7200 i think it's a bit
too much
as a target so i revised my target i use
another method
and i give you 5900 for
2024 something like this so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
update on dspy see you cheers